hi and welcome to my video series of bio
techniques explained in five minutes
where I explain the concept of biology
in less than 5 minutes or so if you
haven't yet subscribe to my channel hit
that subscribe button by the way I'm
also present in an academy and if you
want to join on I could me use my code
epi 10 for getting 10% discount and my
lectures are present there in this
installment we're going to talk about
affinity chromatography as the name
suggests the affinity chromatography the
principle of affinity chromatography is
the affinity interaction between two
molecules so in this lecture let's try
to understand what is their affinity and
what how it is the basis of the
separation just like any chromatographic
technique affinity chromatography is
also used to separate proteins or let's
say nucleic acid or small molecules
chromatographic techniques has four
basic steps equilibration when
equilibrium buffer runs to the column
and make the column weight and make it
more applicable for this sample binding
then the binding step itself where you
provide your sample it might be DNA
might be protein etc and your protein is
bound to the affinity column by a
specific molecular interaction which are
mostly non covalent in nature now the
weak there are also weak and nonspecific
binding which you can get rid of by a
washing step while you wash those with a
specific wash buffer which can denature
the weak interactions but retain the
strong interaction by that you can get
rid of all the nonspecific binding and
they're washed away later you can change
the buffer composition and pH and as a
result you can elute the proteins that
you want to do want to work on so that
is how you can get your purified protein
now affinity purification is based on
the affinity column so this column is
packed with beads and let's take a
simplest example here the bead is
associated with several antibodies which
is distant again this particular protein
which is bluish in color it doesn't bind
to the protein which is brown in color
so in a mixture of protein we have put
these brown protein and this blue
protein but our antibody is destined
again this
particular blue protein so it would
retain that we do protein in the column
and in the wash tip these kind of brown
protein and many other proteins would be
washed away but our protein of interest
would be retained into the column and
after that we can elude that to get our
protein of interest one of the most
popular type of tags that is used these
days is known as his tag protein
purification here you synthesize your
protein in such a way that it has a in
terminal histidine tag a hexa histidine
tag now histidine has a high affinity
for nickel nta matrix now the the
nitrogen of the histidine ring actually
formed coordination bond with the N int
M matrix and that's how it attaches a
protein with the N int M matrix and
that's how the proteins which are
present in the stationary fades get
immobilized on the beads and later by
changing the buffer composition this
coordinate bond can be dissolved and as
a result the proteins can be eluted now
the biggest advantage of this technique
it's very very very specific but also a
disadvantage is like if you use a immuno
affinity based method you might not have
antibody for any type of protein that
you want to purify in that case instead
protein purification or GST tag protein
purification is very useful where you
put the tag and using that tag to anchor
your protein and retain it to the matrix
now in case of his tag routine
purification you first clone your gene
of interest into a plasmid which has a
in terminal hissed at and this
expression vector would express the
protein inside the bacteria with a hiss
tag and as the bacteria grows you get
the bacteria out and smash it and get
the lyse it run it through the column to
purify your protein of interest that is
our histep protein purification works
instead of this histidine tag there
could be other tags such as flat tags
Mik tags or sometime also GST tags so
there are various type of tags but the
principle is very simple you retain that
you retain your annihilate molecule with
the help of these tag because something
is specifically binding with high
Trinity with this tag now for all of
these different type of columns the
basic principle is same first it starts
with equilibration sample binding
followed by wash and illusion and that
is how you get your purified protein
right now not only protein can be
purified within with this technique DNA
can also be purified using affinity
based interaction so there are specific
columns present micro columns which are
present which employs silicon or sodium
silicate as a column material now sodium
silicate is positively charged so it can
retain the DNA which is negatively
charged due to its phosphate backbone
and as a result it would retain the DNA
allow everything else to flow out now
first you add your DNA sample which is
not pure maybe having several other
impurities such as phenol let's say
protein etc allow this thing to pass
through this column and this is the
binding step after that you wash it with
a wash buffer so all the nonspecific
bindings are like washed away and later
on you use an illusion step and
centrifuge it such that you get the
element so the element is your purified
DNA right and this is how you can purify
the DNA using affinity principles there
are recent days development of affinity
chromatography by which you can purify
actively transcribing mRNAs from a cell
and this is called ribosome tagging so
the principle is if a particular point
of time a particular cell is giving rise
to giving rise to specific genes or
expressing some genes
so those genes would be actually present
in the ribosomes and it would be
producing proteins right and now if we
can somehow pull down the ribosomes we
are able to pull down the active
transcript with it so with genetic
method you put a tag in the ribosome and
followed by a antigen let's say the tag
is GFP and followed by an TGIF to bead
you can pull down the whole complex or
beed ribosome and the mRNA along with it
later on you can use qPCR based method
to detect which mRNA actually came down
with it
so it's called a rival pulldown assay
which is also based on the affinity
principle so you can use the same
affinity principle in several different
ways to purify several different type of
annihilate molecules so I hope this
video was informative if you like my
video available it comes up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you